From the world that brought you 1918, 1347,
and Woodstock 99 comes a year.
We can wait to close the book on, even though 2021 is when the real pain begins.
Um, the way, Oops,
spoiler alert on his 20, 20,
after two months of blissful, hedgehog filled ignorance.
I've never felt so alive.
A hot new virus drop that affects everyone equally causing the world to set
aside their differences, work together and cooperate to fight back.
I'm just getting, you know, we all stay doing our same old dumb.
The only thing that actually brought us together was tiger King.
Can you believe that came out only 10 years ago,
tune in to this live action adaptation of the book of revelation,
complete with fires, famine, plagues,
and other signs of the end times featuring lockdowns that have lasted so long.
We've run out of post-apocalyptic movies to compare it to is your sucks.
You guys, this year.
Sucks.
That's all the ammo you've got for this love crafty and elf we're in Patton.
Oswald. Yeah. Yeah. Long time listener.
First time caller making sure you stay brutally honest about 2020.
Remember Avengers end game. I think about it once a day. Of course you do. Okay.
Think about the, on your left moment, right? Cap is down.
The odds are against him suddenly hope,
but then instead of what condoms and wizards and zero body fat hunk coming out
of those portals, there's just human. Just a never ending firehose,
torrent of diarrhea directly into caps, mouth eyeballs, that 2020.
Wow. That is honest. Yeah. More like that. Keep going,
cancel your plans and cover your webcam.
Cause you're not going anywhere all year. It's been 84 years.
And now with HBO treating theaters like Lenny at the end of mice and men,
the new home of entertainment is your home.
And the new home of work is your home.
And the new home of school is your home.
And the new home of your home is out on the street because how the am I supposed
to pay rent? When everything is shut down.
Would it help with my friends? And I saying, imagine for you again. No, look,
how about Fleetwood Mac's dreams. Maybe.
Now, here you go again. You say you won't,
you free hit 'em.
Ah, that's better,
but there is light in the darkness and that light is the glow of the screen.
You're on right now.
As we string so much ISP suddenly remembered they wipe their with net neutrality
two years ago. But until the party's over, we'll keep binging.
The shows that help us escape to the before times, six feet apart, come on.
The VOD releases that have us dropping big bucks,
just for the thrill of watching something new, eh, maybe not,
and enjoying another cozy night in with the loved ones, bitterly,
arguing over what the street.
You've been through the crown twice already.
Can we please watch the wire before a vaccine comes out at FAU.
Program lacks all matter of refinement.
Stop pretending your a Royal. You don't have the breeding Frazier fine.
So let's Pat ourselves on the back for surviving 2020. Even though every year,
the major war depression has been way worse.
We just didn't have Twitter to complain about it.
And let's embrace distractions like social media, movies, TV and games.
Not just because they're helping us to get through these difficult times,
but because staying home all day,
eating snacks on a hot couch is literally saving lives right now.
Okay. You hear that mom now who needs to go outside and play that? Yeah,
go make me some meatloaf. What'd you? My game's about to start.
Starring. No one cared who I was till I put on the bag.
Ask America your screwed America. You're screwed,
but we feel your pain. Number one, film at the box office, bad boys for life.
Finally.
Seeing them aliens.
Greatest of all time for 500.
Just when I think you couldn't possibly be any dumber,
you go and do something like this and.
Totally redeem yourself.
Millions of people speaking up to make their voices heard.
Harassing the Snyder, cut into existence. Stay in alive.
Remember in 2016 with like five celebrities died and everyone said things
couldn't possibly get any worse.
Have you people ever seen a movie? What did you think was going to happen?
I really don't think things could get any worse.
Well, at least it can't get any worse, but at least to can't get any worse.
Or look on the positive side of these things.
Excuse me. Were you going to say worse? No. No. You sure,
absolutely not revise that.
It's got electrical AIDS. It's what plants grave.
Sometimes I doubt your commitment to sparkle motion.
How does it make you feel? When I say the word moist,
it ain't over until Epic voice guy has read the final comment.
2020.